Americans civil rights organizations
used to care about well civil rights
that's not surprising in fact it's good
but recently the n-double-a-cp has
declared that it regards climate change
as a civil rights issue and and said
that Martin Luther King's vision for
America cannot be achieved without quote
environmental justice whatever that is
we spoke to black belt citizens
organized or Porsha Shepherd about this
shift here it is or Shepherd thanks for
coming on thank you so much for having
me Tucker so it's a little bit confusing
for a couple reasons the most obvious is
I agree with both goals but a clean
environment and racial equality but it's
hard to see exactly how they're tied
together how are they well I personally
cannot speak for the n-double-a-cp
but what I can speak for is the
environment and justice that we're
having here in the black belt of Alabama
and part of it is you know as it relates
to what dr. King stood for he stood for
justice and stand up for injustice is
that our happen in all kinds of
communities when you look at here in a
great state of elevate of Alabama it's
not just in the black but of Alabama it
just so happened that in Lawrence County
and in Macon County there experi this
same fight as it relates to
environmental injustice is it just so
happened that in our community majority
of the individuals who are facing these
problems are people of color okay but I
mean by that standard couldn't you say
Martin Luther King fought for justice
and he did and it's unjust for the
government to take most of what you earn
I think we'd all agree they shouldn't
take most of them oh yeah so Martin
Luther King would be in favor of lower
tax rates but he didn't talk about lower
tax rates they didn't talk about global
warming so maybe we shouldn't get him
involved in those issues but it as it
relates to justice and fighting
injustice I'm assuming because I did not
make those particular statements but I'm
assuming because through the legacy of
what dr. King stood for that's the same
message that we're using and the same
the tools that we're using in this fight
for environmental justice when you have
time and time again when you have the
communities especially in the black belt
of Alabama that don't have echoey sewage
you have communities that are being
poisoned right
by coal ash so when you have these
things one would think that it must be a
civil rights issue because a lot of the
communities that are being affected by
this Tucker are people of color so in
that aspect of it I can definitely
understand that yeah I mean I sort of
see what you're saying there's no doubt
that poorer people live in crummy er
places they tend to live in places that
are more polluted there are a bunch of
reasons for that some of them obvious
some of them sinister I agree but I mean
the most polluted places on earth
I don't know Ukraine where the Chernobyl
disaster happened as no people of color
but has a lot of poor people and so I
guess the problem I have with this is if
you frame it as a racial issue then it
scares people and makes them think that
there's a conspiracy to pollute just
because their skin color and if we don't
evidence that have evidence that's true
we probably shouldn't suggest it right I
agree to a certain extent but as far as
the class a point that you made up I
absolutely agree with it that's one of
the reason why part of Lawrence and
Macon County
that's a predominantly white area but
the medium income is it's similar to
what's happening down there in Perry
County which is between ten and
seventeen thousand dollars a year so you
have to say that this is definitely a a
point of class and it's not so much that
we just want to live in a poor area it's
just that me personally I could touch
speak for myself I inherit land in that
particular area I'm not just gonna give
it up because it's a poor area and I
think it's on is is unfair especially
for that particular community where you
have majority of the people who live
that their own their land have to give
it up because you have politicians and
people who are empowered who made a
decision to dump this particular thing
these particular issues on them and
that's one of the fights that black belt
citizens is fighting it's not so much
you know of oh it's civil rights oh it's
black power no it's not about that it's
about helping people stand up for
themselves and get the justice that they
deserve
people deserve clean water mine has no
business buying three to four cases of
water a week just so she can cook a meal
because she's afraid to drink the water
that is coming out of our faucet those
things should not be happening and it
just so happened when you talk about
civil rights issue and you see it in
Lance Conte you see it in Angie's been
you see it definitely in Uniontown
Alabama that these issues are definitely
taking place and it just
happen in that area it is people of
color but it's definitely a class issue
well I gotta say I kind of agree with a
lot of what you're saying and just I
can't resist saying I hope you don't
sell your land because some of the
prettiest places in this country are in
the workplaces or rural areas 1:30 or
than downtown Los Angeles or Beverly
Hills I would say but in a lot safer
yeah let's say for a nicer people but
maybe part of the problem is that the
people in charge ignore and exploit
rural America do you ever think of that
oh absolutely you just hit the nail I
mean it and it goes back to their class
statement that you made earlier it goes
right back to that you know even though
I'm doing the same stuff you're in doing
but because I got a little bit more than
you then I could I can keep you I could
feel like I'm a little I'm above it and
that's the biggest issue of it all and
so that's what dr. King was about you
know there poor Pete campaigning he was
getting ready kicked out before his
assassination you know it was poor
people he didn't say poor blacks he said
poor people and that's important to
understand that when you see it time and
time again environmental justice
throughout this great nation it is
specifically in poor community and more
than likely people of color will be
affected by that yeah like I kind of
agree with what you're saying I like
gorillas and I appreciate your coming on
tonight Portia thanks a lot thank you so
much Tara thank you so much for having
us